y en directo a vamos hasta caracas y
allá y saludamos a nuestra corresponsal
daniela zambrano para hablar de una
reunión que tuvo lugar en la ciudad
colombiana de cúcuta frontera con
venezuela pues allí se reunieron
representantes gubernamentales y
empresarios de ambos países un primer
acercamiento para restablecer sus
relaciones comerciales daniela buenas
noches cuéntenos qué se sabe sobre este
encuentro
hola qué tal muy buenas noches fueron
cerca de 300 empresarios entre
venezolanos y colombianos que acudieron
a este encuentro en cúcuta allí no se
habló de una fecha específica para la
reapertura de la frontera entre colombia
y venezuela pero el ministro de comercio
de colombia dijo que sería pronto a
corto plazo pero que primero deberían
garantizarse condiciones en materia de
seguridad y también en materia
diplomática se habló incluso de crear un
pase especial para que los ciudadanos
puedan pasar de una forma más fácil de
un lado a otro y quien fue designado
como embajador de colombia en venezuela
hermano benedetti quien estuvo presente
en este foro habló incluso de
digitalizar lo que con la huella los
ciudadanos pudiesen pasar el ministro de
transporte de colombia también dijo que
los puentes fronterizos ya estaban
listos para poder ser reabiertos
recordemos que estos están cerrados
desde hace siete años había preocupación
por el estado de estos puentes por el
lado venezolano se habló además en este
foro de hacer
a una zona económica de crear una zona
económica
diferencial con excepción de impuestos
para que funcionaran en la frontera y lo
que más jugó fue la disposición de ambos
lados para que se reanude el comercio
entre ambos países recordemos que las
relaciones diplomáticas entre venezuela
y colombia se rompieron en el año 2019
pero justamente este viernes se cumplen
siete años del cierre de los pasos
fronterizos a propósito de este tema que
usted menciona daniela en qué va el
proceso para restablecer las relaciones
diplomáticas
bueno precisamente este jueves también
félix plasencia quien fue designado como
embajador de venezuela en colombia
acudió a la asamblea nacional presentó
su plan de trabajo ante la comisión de
política exterior y posteriormente por
unanimidad se aprobó el acuerdo para su
designación como embajador de venezuela
en colombia recordemos también que ya el
canciller de venezuela había dicho que
el gobierno de gustavo petro ya había
otorgado el beneplácito para que félix
plascencia asumiera como embajador el
ministro de transporte de colombia que
también estuvo en este encuentro que se
realizó en computable incluso de la
reanudación de vuelos entre bogotá y
caracas estimaba que esto podría ser en
octubre y dijo que no que no descartaba
de que pronto pudiese haber un encuentro
entre el presidente nicolás maduro y
gustavo petro